[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] هل هناك أي سيناريو يكون فيه الرئيس
بايدن
راضيًا عن نتيجة غير حاسمة
لأصل الوباء  التي قتلت
الكثير من الأمريكيين يمكنني أن أؤكد لك أن
الرئيس يريد الوصول إلى
الأسباب الجذرية لـ kovid 19 التي
قتلت كما أشرت مئات
الآلاف من الأمريكيين وأتمنى أن يكون
هناك المزيد من العمل في وقت سابق
للوصول إلى  أسفلها
وبالطبع لإنقاذ المزيد من الأرواح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لكنهم يريدون استخدام الصين كرجل قش
يعني حارس التعري الذي تعرفه
للتغلب على المرض الداخلي في
الانقسام الداخلي للولايات المتحدة
ولهذا السبب  لقد طلب من مجتمع الاستخبارات
إجراء 90 يومًا من
تقرير التحقيق المزعوم من ناحية أخرى ،
بالطبع يمكن أن يدفع الآخرين الذين تعرفهم
30 أمرًا على الصين
لجعل الصين تهرب
بسبب عدم كفاءة حكومة الولايات المتحدة بالكامل
في المدى.
إدارة الوباء
[موسيقى]
لك